papapapa comment ça va aujourd'hui on va
visiter mon petit studio hop je peux pas
rentrer toi bats tu as mis du temps à
comprendre la blague des demandes
bienvenue dans ce premier espace
privatisé
c'est là où je tourne toutes mes vidéos
partant john tu as payé la taxe juppé
nadon bureau donc tu dois être une caste
c'est quoi ça c'est une tirelire [ __ ]
c'est une forme c'est pour mettre fin
aux idées mais la pièce michael 11 ans
de m'étouffer dans un sac en plastique
j'appelle l'ambulance dionne 1000 pesos
talent clos bien ça me donne tu m'as
volé tu m'as volé revient là on est donc
dans mon bureau bien venu voilà allez on
passe à autre chose ici qu'est ce que
c'est qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
capteur d'acheter ses vibes pourquoi on
fait une vidéo htc va il y en a un autre
juste là tu peux le film et c'est
justement on a ici un casque ouvert
watchers à jack apparemment chaque
minute passée à jouer overblog avec le
casse-cou vers moi tu te rend plus fort
sur l'objet ce qu'on va dire lâche temps
c'est faux c'est hyper faux parce que je
me sens bien ici on a un peu pied de
basse qualité ne l'achetez pas un retour
le ninja blade de chez atom heart qui
marche une fois sur 10 avec mon appareil
qui est un sony alpha synthes est ce que
c'est la france intéresse des gens bons
prends mon dieu c'est oppresseurs qui
brille de partout j'adore chiens qui
courent ça c'est mon troisième bras tout
ça offre une certaine liberté de
montblanc qui peut faire ça très
lentement avec ton troisième voir si tu
as un bras nul au nom l'acheter explique
au nom suite alors mais pourquoi il fait
ça mais les coûts mais tokyo
ici on a une carte son externe la focus
trail de i2 cap besan 8 relié à un ampli
apparemment un db x professional
producteurs qui permet quand je crie de
compression pour pas que ça sature et
que ça vous défense les oreilles tu me
fais jones john tu vois c'est les
meilleurs plaques isolantes d'europe
ah non pardon ça c'est la partie ou
l'enculé d'ouvriers n'a pas terminé les
pauses est ici on a la meilleure mousse
d'europe si je crie et que je pas r tu
m'entends d'un plus c'est quand même pas
un truc tu vois ça je ne peux acheter
pour la vidéo qu'on a fait avec tienne
on a créé un homme
un petit délai avec la musique et j'ai
lancé un logiciel j'ai fait une heure et
puis j'ai plus jamais retouché à trévé
jusqu'à ce que yann bien tourné cette
vidéo dont je fais gagner voilà mettez
un pouce vert abonnez-vous et dit autour
de vous vous adorez la chaîne youtube
ok on passe à la suite bienvenue dans le
salon de tech dans lequel il ya une
machine à café est pas une machine à
terre j'ai pu de calcul depuis 6 ans
année petit coin pour accueillir les
amis alors ça si je puis me permettre
c'est le côté bio j'ai voulu la jouer
pour 2016 selon nicolas hulot donc j'ai
acheté des petites plantes de la verdure
ces défauts ce qui fait le wii speak to
écologique du plastique et j'ai acheté
cet auteur pour toi parce que john je
suis un grand fan de cap la réponse est
oui peut faire des constructions
voilà je te présente alfa-beta 08 j'ai
acheté pourquoi parce que quand je dis
le moi fdp qui tue le fdp le plus proche
[ __ ] j'ai tout de suite été avec des
paires ici nous avons le plus grand
rival de notre vie d'après faire
bonjour je suis douté longtemps jalousie
je suis sûr imparable merci à tous ici
qu'est ce qu'on a on a un deuxième poste
pourquoi la deuxième pause je ne peux
que je puisse jouer pendant que mon
clown esclaves travail indique reculait
tu m'as parlé d'un jaune c'est hyper
important c'est le signal de détresse
loi défaut les abonnés le week-end il
n'y a pas de vidéo ils ont besoin de
leur dose de vidéos ils viennent ici
mais de salaire l'eau comme ça le vélo
ça te fait penser à quoi m ouais sauf
que les pas de google
ça coûtait trop cher tu vois ce qui est
beau soleil que youtube c'est ce partage
ce lien a allumée cette lumière pour me
montrer à travers la lumière je leur
apporte un petit peu de particules
positive grâce aux vidéos tu
comprendrais si l'allégorie dans un
oxymore 21
alors j'ai touché par cette plante te
demandes ce qui allait à cette porte
d'un local ménages mais tu sais ce qu'il
ya dans ce cas ménage dans votre fonds
entre deux petits coude à ce qu il est
là je pense à lui
il me donne du courage tu sais je
m'interdis de porter plus de 20 secondes
par jour parce qu'après qu'on prend la
grosse tête
ici c'est un petit frigo parce que qu
une vidéo à vide et je me console comme
je peux
je te dise que c'est ces piments plus
fort du monde dans cinq ados de mammites
wink a bizarrement il est encore là
c'était ya deux ans qu'ils nous faire et
surtout je t'en ai pas parlé que j'aime
plus que tout dans la vie c'est les
fléchettes
je crois que c'est truqué ça
détrompe-toi vraiment potes avant de
clore cette vidéo j'aimerais te monte un
truc que j'ai montré à très peu de gens
ces statuettes
aux couleurs de youtube cette erreur
2016 youtube a sorti une loi visant à
supprimer les vidéos des gens qui était
vulgaire
du coup on a dû mener une vraie
évolution on a les mêmes bien petit
slogan la liberté ou la mort certains
youtuber ont choisi la mort je peux voir
la tête de cyprien dans ce sens des
sorties on a gagné mais c'était dû à un
rude combat
est une gageure m la pièce a tellement
tellement